thanks to the Google pixel 7 Pro for
sponsoring this video
who are you who are you
no no you stay away you stay away no
foreign
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that definitely isn't standing
right behind you
spend any time watching the channel
recently you know that we are in love
with the world of analog horror there
are countless incredible independent
filmmakers here on YouTube telling some
of the most compelling and scariest
stories in modern entertainment right
now I'm talking stuff like the Walton
files the back rooms the Mandela catalog
stories that all have an iconic look and
feel because they're largely set in the
80s 90s and early odds this was a time
when video tech was first becoming
widely available in finding its footing
camcorders were giant boxes that you had
to cart around with you and if you
actually wanted to film something well
you also had to bring along a library's
worth of physical tapes to record on no
exaggeration my family had a literal
cooler sized bag just to carry
everything we needed to film like 30
minutes of the family Christmas and even
then the footage we got was rough and
something moved the footage got blurry
when it was dark it got grainy most of
the time you just left what you shot on
the recording tapes because transferring
it to an actual VHS tape you could play
required a master's degree in arranging
wires and cables from the camcorder to
the VCR are and then once you actually
watched what you made your mileage
varied yes and no one watching right now
has ever even heard of a tracking button
on a remote control before right that
ringing bells for anyone well you know
those blurry lines that go across the
screen and pretty much all analog horror
uploads those were most often caused by
a misalignment of the tape inside the
VHS and the playback head inside the VCR
and tracking was the button that you
used to help sync those two things up
this is the awkward puberty era of tech
that I'm talking about and that's what I
love about these analog horror series
they're videos that take the early
limitations of tech from the era and use
them to create genuine authentic
memorable scares now at the top of the
episode you heard that this video is
being sponsored by the Google pixel 7
Pro fact that whole opening was filmed
on the phone's camera a camera that just
has a ton of amazing features we had to
work really hard to make the footage
from this thing look old and scary like
analog horror just take a look at this
this is the final shot but watch as we
remove one filter to get rid of the
vignette a final effect boom this is the
original footage that we were working
with and it looks fantastic fantastic
which got me thinking what would modern
analog horror look like the aesthetic of
analog horror is built off these
technological limitations of 80s and 90s
home video motion blur no ability to see
in the dark things that are just barely
visible off in the distance but those
limitations don't exist today just look
at the Google pixel 7 Pro a phone small
enough to fit in your pocket but
equipped with a camera smart enough to
challenge Tech 10 times its size motion
blur isn't a problem because it has
image stabilization in fact the blur is
in your control with features like
cinematic blur keeping the subject in
focus and blurring the background is it
too dark not a problem the Google pixel
7 Pro has night sights where you can
take a picture in almost absolute
darkness and still wind up with
something to show for it oh is there
something off in the distance that's too
far to truly make out again it's not a
problem this itty bitty piece of tech
now has a five time zoom telephoto lens
and Records in 4k so that scary pile of
pixels off in the woods is just the
non-scary pile of rocks that it always
was I gotta be honest with you we have
great cameras here in the studio Studio
to film on but most of the shoots that
we do at this point are on Pixel phones
because the cameras are high quality
they're easy to use and they're smart
the shots look better because the camera
is largely doing a lot of the work for
us so this then begs the question is
modern technology too good to make
effective analog horror could an analog
horror series take place in the modern
day when everyone and their grandmother
has access to a high quality camera
sitting in their pocket today we're
looking at the tropes of analog horror
to see what the equivalent would be if
it was themed around today in 20 to 30
years when people look back at this era
of entertainment what will the Retro
Tech horror stories look and feel like
curl up and hide under the blankets
loyal theorists we're about to find out
so before we can really jump into the
idea of modern tech being too good to
make analog horror we should first take
a step back to fully understand what
makes the 80s and 90s Tech so perfect
for this type of Storytelling like I
mentioned in the intro series like the
Walton files back rooms Mandela catalogs
all of them are made to look like they
were filmed on Ancient camcorders they
have that iconic jittery blurry EHS look
this sort of Technology became cheap
enough to mass produce by the 1980s and
were fairly common by the 1990s that's
why so many of these series take place
in this era of content it's also where
we get the analog part of the label
analog horror these old camcorders used
analog signals to write information onto
actual magnetic strips an analog signal
is basically some sort of thing that
constantly changes to represent
different data points this could be the
Heights or frequencies of wavelengths
like with radio signals or even stuff
that's simple like a record where it
reads the heights of grooves on the
record and then translates that into an
audio output because analog recordings
are literal waves there's an infinite
amount of detail that you can get in
there but it also makes it more likely
to have interference like you see with
television static hence why old TVs had
antennas that you could use to fine-tune
the signal by contrast digital signals
are discrete packages that are stored as
units of ones and zeros a digital
recording takes snapshots of the analog
signal at a certain rate a higher the
rate the closer to the original signal
you're gonna get instead of encoding
information onto a physical tape like
with animal analog digital signals store
it onto memory cards anyway at that time
analog tapes had the potential to be
decent quality but it turns out that the
tech wasn't exactly the ideal solution
for long-term storage seat Magnetic Tape
begins to degrade after 10 to 20 years
if it isn't stored properly meaning the
footage gets blurry it gets glitchy
corrupted here's a friendly reminder to
convert all your old home videos into
digital if you haven't already here
folks what's more the footage from these
old cameras and camcorders was often
interlaced have you ever paused an old
video and noticed that any motion blur
seems to have this weird series of
horizontal lines running through it that
means that the footage was interlaced
each single frame of the video only had
about half the information needed for
the full image the rest of the image
used the previous frame meaning that any
motion would be slightly offset and thus
the horizontal lines this drastically
cut the amount of data needed for the
full video making it easier to both
store and broadcast but it also resulted
in huge losses in quality the opposite
of this is known as progressive scan
where an entire image's worth of video
is shown in each individual frame you
ever notice when you select the quality
of a YouTube video it says something
like 1080p well the P stands for
progressive scan and almost all video
shot today uses that as the standard
regardless the lower quality interlaced
video being played on a big old CRT
screen help to create the iconic
flickering look that we now associate
with old videos from this era and you
see that's why it works so well for
Horror made on a budget not only is this
sort of Technology really cheap nowadays
but the look is easy to recreate in
post-production using modern editing
software like here bam our editors just
threw a bunch of effects on this to make
it look like an old VHS and it's what
like two layers in After Effects this
lets young filmmakers create something
that's immediately stylish atmospheric
set in a clear time and place in history
what's more important though is that
they're also able to use this aesthetic
to amplify what makes the series scary
this look creates an intentional lack of
clarity see when you introduce a scary
idea but you don't show that scary thing
what your audience imagines in their
head is far more horrifying than
anything you could possibly come up with
yourself it doesn't matter what Medium
you're in in the idea is used to great
effect in the Cthulhu Mythos books and a
ton of the most iconic horror movies of
all time have embraced this exact idea
is your mechanical shark animatronic not
working don't worry just don't show the
shark for the majority of the movie and
it's gonna wind up being way more
effective and way scarier and it's this
lack of clarity that really intensifies
the actual horror that analog horror is
based on that what's familiar can be
deadly look at the three series that I
keep using as examples Mandela catalog
is all about our friends and Neighbors
being imposters the Walton files is
about a family-friendly burger
restaurant that turns deadly and the
back rooms is about the horror of
mundane walls and fluorescent lights
these aren't supernatural creatures
these are series that rely on the normal
people and places around us that made
unnatural and scary this idea that the
familiar can hurt you is probably best
exemplified by another Trend that came
out of this era stranger danger though
the term dates back all the way to the
1960s it didn't catch fire until 1979
when a child in Manhattan was tragically
kidnapped while walking to school news
media grabbed hold of the story who
spread it nationwide and soon began
widely reporting similar cases of
missing kids this culminated in 1982
when it was widely reported that nearly
50 000 American children were being
kidnapped by strangers every year and uh
just so were crystal clear on this that
number is wildly inflated but it managed
to cement the idea that all strangers
can be potentially dangerous in the
minds of the nation and there were PSAs
and school assemblies drilling that idea
into people throughout the 80s and 90s
even up through the mid-2000s but these
analog horror series also play off
another innate human Fear The Uncanny
Valley this is a phenomenon that many
psychologists have noticed where people
have strong negative reactions to things
that look Almost Human but aren't quite
all the way there insert any low budget
poorly executed CGI here but again this
is where analog horror shines without
the budget to pay for pristine photo
realistic computer generated worlds
these stories lean into the unsettling
nature of things that are slightly off
from reality the alternates from Mandela
catalog are stretched deformed human
monsters they're almost human but not
quite the animatronics of Walton's
restaurants exhibit jerky movements and
speak in dead emotionless pre-recorded
phrases the back rooms takes a generic
office layout but then twists it into
something that's not built by human
hands something that on the surface
looks familiar but where the nuances
don't match up the layout doesn't quite
work with what those spaces would
actually look and feel like if it was
actually made by humans things are just
slightly off which keeps us off balance
and nervous but having laid all of that
out you can start to see the problem
here right modern technology just isn't
super compatible with that flavor of
classic analog horror our cameras are
too good and there's just a lot of them
everywhere and even if you are working
with older blurry footage today there
are upscaling programs that are able to
use complex algorithms to increase the
quality of footage near flawlessly so if
we were to sit here and think about what
modern analog horror would be what would
it look like if current analog horror
thrives on the limitations of the
technology from the past what will the
creators of the future be exploiting to
scare us with stories about today since
Clarity of image isn't an issue anymore
we need to find something about
contemporary technology that is scary
honestly I had to really think about
this one I mean there are some obvious
answers like social media and that
everyone shares a ton of information
about themselves online and not everyone
is what they seem but that's not super
unique those stories are already being
told by Hollywood we all understand the
scare potential there it's also not a
true parallel to analog horror again the
genre is about the limitations of
filming equipment equipment that today
seems to have no limitation and therein
lies the answer I think that right there
is the point not that the video gets
blurry in the darker that a shaky camera
obscures the movement of a monster as it
comes towards you in an ironic twist
where analog horror as we know it's
rooted in the limitations of Technology
from the 80s and 90s I expect creators
of analog Horror in the future to lean
into the idea that technology became too
good in the 2020s that what we Define as
photorealism has actually evolved Beyond
reality now able to create realities
that never even existed in the the first
place what made me think of this was
actually the pixel 7. there's this
feature in the camera called Magic
Eraser which lets you go into your
photos after you take them to remove
small objects in the background it does
this using AI filling in the space left
by the object with information about the
space around it it is without
exaggeration an incredible tool it helps
you to create the perfect moment even if
you weren't able to capture it at the
time I cannot tell you the amount of
times that Steph and I have woken up at
4am just to get a picture in front of
some Landmark without hordes of people
lingering in the background Magic Eraser
solves that problem instantly getting me
extra sleep while we're on vacation
which I am so thankful for but magic
eraser also shows how instantaneous this
sword attack is getting literally you
rub your finger and stuff in the
background disappears it erases people
out of a moment in time it is literally
creating a new reality with just the
touch of a finger and sure this sort of
stuff has always been possible to some
extent thanks to photo editing software
but the ease and speed at which it's
possible now with the Magic Eraser is
incredible and we're not just talking
about correcting photos either I'm sure
you've seen the news about AI with the
ability to create artwork from using
just a few keywords my friends over at
Corridor Digital have been experimenting
with this sort of content creation for a
while now let me tell you AI image
generation is even getting to a point
where you feed it a bunch of pictures of
an individual person and you can get it
to spit out high quality artistic
interpretations of that person in almost
any style you want no joke companies are
already starting to talk to me about how
this sort of technological advancement
could be used to automatically generate
video thumbnails in the near future and
it's not just stopping it's still images
either we've already done two episodes
dedicated to the ways that Hollywood has
taken people's likenesses and putting
them onto other bodies how are now able
to synthesize voices from audio clips
things like that there are even computer
programs that allow you to take the
voices of real people and convert them
into AI voices so you can then get those
voices to say anything you want and
again people are contacting me about
this exact sort of thing so that my
auto-generated voice can exist forever
reading these scripts as the Eternal
online theorist and this is no longer a
cumbersome process either it's getting
to the point where you can literally
deep fake some one in real time on video
calls I mean can you imagine how
frightening it would be if these
Technologies combined and you could
speak with someone's actual voice and
face that's not only terrifying it's
also incredibly believable in the near
future and if I were to make any sort of
modern analog horror set in the present
day it would Embrace this technology for
its storytelling it would have to be
about ai's creating a reality that was
never actually real in the first place
so say we wanted to make something
similar to the Mandela catalog the
alternates an intruder could be people
deep faked in real time on the surface
they look normal but something about
them is just off or they don't sound
quite right it could be about tricking
you into false memories about your own
life an AI serving up videos of things
that you've said and done that you know
that you have never said or done before
your memory is being gaslit and your
physical body being erased for moments
in time that you know you were there for
but slowly bit by bit the evidence
starts to stack up against you picks or
it didn't happen you know and the picks
don't show you for whatever reason the
back rooms are even easier to work with
here a running Theory has been that the
world of the back rooms is just one big
simulated reality that's become glitched
something that becomes a lot scarier if
we imagine an AI Overlord tweaking
things and people in real time changing
a face here creating a neighborhood out
of thin air there when it detects a
problem it over corrects its reality
perhaps leading people to glitch out in
the first place instead of the
intentional lack of clarity like with
the 80s and 90s Air Attack here we're
leaning into the hyper reality of all of
this there's too much detail there's too
much Precision so much in fact that you
begin to doubt yourself your memories
your own identity humans are fallible
the computer's memory meanwhile is not
the big themes of this modern analog
horror would come down to having your
viewers question if what they're seeing
is even real and whether or not we're
just seeing a reality through computers
or if we're seeing what's actually in
front of our faces now that is
terrifying someone should probably do a
series like that someday huh but hey you
know what isn't scary the brand spanking
new Google pixel 7 Pro real talk I adore
the Google pixel series of phones I've
been using them since gen 1 and like I
said at the top of the video a lot of
Team theorist is like me and have been
using them for years Lee who's been on
the team longer than almost anyone here
he's been using a pixel 2 XL since it
came out and loves it to pieces and
after getting some Hands-On time with
the pixel 7 for this video you can't
wait to upgrade and get one for himself
the phone has a ton of other awesome new
features that we didn't get a chance to
touch on today including a live
translation feature that can interpret
and translate 48 languages in real time
there's also a live caption feature that
basically takes any speech audio running
through the phone and captions it in
real time we use captions a lot during
our research so this one is a lifesaver
plus the phone itself looks gorgeous
there's this new metal bar running
across the camera that not only offers
protection but also really pops against
the color of the phone looks awesome
again thank you so much to Google and
the pixel 7 Pro for sponsoring this
video and letting us film this video and
as always remember it's just a theory a
film Fury and cuts
foreign
[Music]
[Music]